[Music]
well it's a book of too honest trailer
commentaries the show where we talk
about the show you hopefully just
watched which was the honest trailer for
all of the Star Wars spin-offs the
original Star Wars before you go C solo
we thought we would harken back to a
time when Star Wars was still pretty
exploitive and still made dumb spin-off
cash grabs yeah because we are out of
Star Wars movies to do are we well we
could have done the Clone Wars movie I
guess or the Clone Wars TV series rebel
big undertaking or rebels but those are
both TV shows and we have a 50 year plus
year TV show that we're currently
working on soon ever before another TV
show yeah this is what was left but
we're talking about the milking of the
original trilogy original trilogy still
a thing with rogue one and solo yeah
still going strong and force awakens
still going strong after all these years
I think it was just an independent
business owner milking it exactly doing
it for himself
that's right I only knew one of the Ewok
movies existed caravan of courage I
didn't know battle for Endor was even a
thing
yep and I had heard tales of the holiday
special I'd seen you know lumpy here and
there but I never sat down and watched
it this was your first for me too I've
never seen any of these and so we had to
go for YouTube like you can't even buy
it really not legally not legally link
and and find a copy online what a week
Ursa
now go because I get one what a mindfuck
that was so bizarre and but so a product
of its time but also something that will
never happen again it's crazy yeah I
think it's not in the fine well you'll
see in the deleted scenes we attempted
to like interpret how weird it would be
today but I don't even know if that's
like watching it like having just seen
Star Wars the biggest movie of all time
I can't imagine the amount of excitement
like this is this was new Star Wars yeah
this was the first new Star Wars since
Star Wars and everybody was there like
they were all in it I have the whole gay
God like it's
oh man I can't imagine what that was
like it's incredible it's yeah and we
should have done well I don't know who
exactly green leaded or whose idea it
was but the way it was sold to George I
remember reading was this will be good
promotion for the upcoming movies right
like this will keep people interested in
the interim okay I wish I had realized
it was yours first time watching just so
I could have paid attention to both of
you to see how long it took for 30
straight minutes of Wookiee growling to
just break you oh yeah like they'll
never stop growling yeah there's so many
parts of my note to like wow still going
peripherally over and over again and and
but the Christmas special was at least
our holiday special like damn Carter
[Laughter]
those Starbucks cups are the same color
as the Imperial Guardsmen yeah the Ewok
movies broke me was watching those
back-to-back just the four-year-old and
the Ewok is they're slow and they're
boring at least the holiday special
would give you something like
interesting every five minutes to have
your jaw drop at yeah the reality
television show yeah roll with the
pouring is and then like it just does
this creepy fade-out where like
everybody else in the bar leaves it's
just a name in her remaining and it's
just a creepy fade to black like what
does he do to her after it fades to
black so weird
I don't know me well sure you just watch
the trailer yeah I guess it shows man we
can pause and discuss as it comes up
we actually found requests for oh yeah
many and forgot this to be a TV trailer
for so low milks your nostalgia for the
original trilogy dry discover three
spin-offs that took everything you loved
about the old Star Wars movies and gave
you something let's just say different
[Music]
dumb as that is I would watch a cooking
show set in the Star Wars universe under
pursue yeah Gore Monda yeah I would want
yeah core - teachers how to make blue
milk Gore Monda teaches you how to make
other yeah think about in sci-fi is like
chefs in science fiction universes with
multiple alien species you have to know
they're like doctors like they have to
know so much about like different
physiologies what they eat taste
preferences and stuff like that like
they must be really really knowledgeable
they must be I don't even know where you
draw the line between what's food and
what's to walk around worse I mean
that's a whole other more gray area you
recently went home and when you came
back you brought us gifts I did and you
brought me back a star wars novel I did
and I've been reading it oh happy
visiting oh nice
it's my training book and they're just
there's so much of it what the main bad
guy has like a personal chef and so much
of it is devoted to stuff the personal
chef does like he does all this weird
stuff with bugs okay and it's it's just
pages and pages and pages and I'm like
yeah this is very solid use of the Star
Wars world building you know Game of
Thrones a George Martin we were tied by
he's always going on about like the meat
pies and the lamb is a kind of pie we do
only teach you how to make a wedding
cake with birds in it yes wedding cake
with birds and then the best way to load
your crossbow and where you should sit
to murder the person that eats it no
there you go there you go perfect
let's keep watching the video the
spin-offs
kick off an evening of crap with caravan
of courage the Ewok movie set before the
other Ewok movie but after the movie
that was he walks embark on an adventure
with no one's favorite unblinking murder
bears as they team up with another
creature that's better in small doses a
kid together they'll search for her
missing parents with her brother mace a
skywalker knockoff with the hair of luke
and the acting of anakin
[Music]
weird thing to say that isn't about
really and that's the weird thing to say
and also go back when you can JT to a
shot of that kid because I have this
theory today's look is dad was a
hammerhead shark he looks to me like the
exact genetic clone of Harrison Ford and
Mark Hamill it's like literally if you
mash the two of them together
it's that kid is it just me which was
bizarre if there's a scene where he
points then that's what's really gonna
sell it for me it I don't know like I
see both of their faces in his face so
much Harrison but I do see Mark Hamill
yeah he's got like the lower mouth
Harrison Ford and the upper head of Mark
Hamill it's weird it's I see a little
more Hayden in there there could be a
little Hayden yeah I don't know that
that I'm just saying that could be the
first Skywalker solo child somehow I
don't know how Ray's dad confirmed
that's where his father exactly that's
Ray's father
you heard it here we we broke it sorry I
that distracted me the whole movie
continued it looks like
see that Disney buy out really early huh
if caravan of courage is the Hobbit then
get ready cuz battle of endor is Game of
Thrones without western attire darkest
Star Wars movie ever made
where most of the Ewoks are slaughtered
in the opening scene the four-year-olds
whole family is massacred yeah they
don't undo that now the the brother the
protagonist from the from the previous
movie and her parents about which the
entire last movie on them getting back
together are killed off screen yeah in
the screen
gone dead forever no no take backs plus
they recast the dad with like a name
yeah get the horns yeah Paul Gleason
from Breakfast Club die hard many
classic 80s movies and other things you
don't yeah you'll see him in a second
gone to edge and she accepts all this
with like the stoic confidence of a
future Sirica joke about but if she is
like unfazed by everything that happens
to her she's just like alright we're
gonna go take the next step and and also
most of the e walks like I think there's
like seven of them yeah at the end what
a dead Ewoks many dead Ewok yeah
many Ewoks died to bring it Wow
that's dark let's see she's kidnapped by
a dragon and has to spend the rest of
her life getting yelled at by Wilford
Brimley I don't want you here get out
someone for life holy crap this is a
Captain phasma prequel isn't it
but those are just warm-ups for the main
event watch the original Star Wars
trilogy lose its final shred of dignity
in the Star Wars Holiday Special a
project so bad George Lucas wanted to
destroyed forever
and that guy made attack of the clones
this Phegley Star Wars theme variety
show where the only variety is the level
of drugs they were on when they wrote it
whether it's a song from Mos Eisley
cantina owner Bea Arthur justify the
cantina band it's not like a musical
where the music's coming from nowhere
she's like and Alya they're into two and
this is that one song they play it just
slowed down yeah life is very fish your
song at the end kind of it's sort of
it's like but it loses sync as it goes
until eventually it's like competing
with it who knew that all of John
Williams themes had lyrics to the lyric
from Superman dude that's what Lois Lane
is saying and the can you read my mind
like those are the lyrics to that maybe
there aren't lyrics to all of John
Williams songs I bet they're crazy yeah
yeah this was Jefferson Starship
I'd say boy saw printers layout while
Harrison Ford regrets all of his life
choices last time you know that's the
face of a man who has a really bad
feeling about this
oh no between the he does until that I
will you go watch the Han Solo things
from the holiday special he is a hundred
percent fully committed the only one who
showed up to work you believe that he is
getting Chewbacca back to his planet
he's like cardboard millennium no card
like really shaky m'lady yeah he's there
too like this I think was the movie that
told him that trying is overrated I
think that's what it was this he's never
done this and looked at it he's like
this is no never again
I'm coast alone feels like Galaxy Quest
when he's like oh this is a lot better
these cardboard ones usually do yeah
taking swigs oh yeah no he tries really
hard and yeah this is what Brooke never
again they're very good poor guy cuz
Hamels sure as hell checked out and yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's in between the
talent sections enjoy a tiny scrap of
story tying it all together there's
where you doing there has to get down
cause in the cantina they have all the
really should be aliens that got cut out
in the special editions like they have
the Wolfman you have like Dracula
Lucifer yeah Lucifer that's a he's a
variant I think budget devil Halloween
costume any budget Wolfman Halloween
costume you can call it a wolf run I if
you want all I'm saying is if they
aren't in solo I'm gonna be pissed they
will they're part of the Lord sections
enjoy a tiny scrap of story tying it all
together where Chewie has to get home to
his beloved itchy mala and lumpy for
life day which is like Christmas but
hairy and vaguely Wiccan
the Empire is a new home but with no
help from Luke or Chewbacca noise
Chewbacca neither Chewbacca or han solo
to the screen please an actual help from
one half of The Honeymooners art corny I
brought you that proton pack what can i
call it babe the thingamabob Chuy's
family will spend over an hour
horrific Lee groaning at each other
while you try to maintain your last
shred of sanity
[Music]
yeah it's like a silent film but not
silent if like Charlie Chaplin oh yeah
I'm like you shot it never cut to that
screen where they tell you what they're
saying it's so much groaning it really
is 20 minutes until they stop groaning
or they cut up they have so many
different like holographic displays and
screens that they keep cutting to just
as an excuse to like get away from the
Wookiee house yeah
but otherwise it's all groaning so
here's the thing on set when they were
shooting it were they saying the English
version of what those lines were or was
it just dead silence and just like the
sound of front of make up mouths just
going let's go again Oh although the
only thing that would now turn me around
on attack of a note was it would be
Revenge of the Sith is in Kashyyyk when
Yoda is there yeah hanging out with his
friends right before he gets turned on
the Jefferson Starship Hollow should
have been playing on a table in the
background that's like do you well much
like solo this project lost its director
halfway through filming and it was
replaced by someone who is just willing
to get it done you have true fact yes so
maybe there was two competing ideas of
what the Wookiees should be saying maybe
there weren't so Mel your brain with the
Star Wars film so awful you'll never
complain about the prequels the last
Jedi or solo again because no matter
what Disney decides to throw it is next
there's no way it will be as bad as
Chuy's dad watching VR porn in the
middle of the living room
did I just dream that oh no no there it
is
that was real oh we are excited
oh geez turn it off turn it off buzz I
read that initially Han Solo was
supposed to be married to a Wookiee
tell us more
just that Jordan has had more of a open
mind about in this galaxy a long time
ago far far away that there would be
more human alien commingling commingling
hmm yeah so he did it all for the
Wookiee he did it all for the look but
yeah it just I don't really understand
what's going on in that scene but well
if it's George back then based on some
of the Raiders of the Lost Ark outlines
it was lumpy wookies underage yeah that
was a weird that's a really weird scene
I know it's just another way to
introduce another 70s like disco era
musical number yeah but to have it be
like his the instantiation of like his
deepest fantasies to come talk to him
and then he's make the noises take on a
sexual tone are sexual wookie yeah
that's one it's super weird just my Star
Wars funk cover band be freaky Yeah
right yeah gross stuff check it out for
yourself on YouTube story love it baby
at least Warwick Davis got paid you're a
hairy wizard diabeetus origins live
isn't Wilford Brimley dropping the
f-bomb and at Emo's is a good question
listen carefully
Shepard was that Wilford Brimley
dropping the f-bomb let's hear it let's
hear it can we slow it down for children
[Music]
what elegantly sounds like it rock rock
rock did they just leave it it may be
yeah I don't know Internet bomb it
certainly sounds like it I can't imagine
what other thing ends in uck
that's one syllable long that you would
yell after something's broke one more
time it certainly sounds yeah all right
all right now you be the judge yep the
star destroyer Malibu Luke Carrie Fisher
giving zero she gets lumpy Space Prince
and he did it all for the wookie Star
Wars the first sellouts you know the
weirdest thing about these movies is the
first appearance of Boba Fett and it's
awesome I take it you have no love of
the Empire
I don't follow me friend yeah
electricity for it feels like a weird
like Ralph Bakshi Star Wars yeah it's
super weird I'd watch the hell out of a
feature-length version of that when they
did the droids show which i think is
kind of in the same style yeah quite
it's cool yeah everyone looks really
weird Han Solo's face looks like Mack
tonight there's so much weird 70s
animation yeah that is worth seeking out
along those lines like there's a movie
called Rock and rule you should watch
because it's just so much weird [ __ ]
from back then before all animation was
either Disney or Pixar yeah yeah there's
a lot of weird one offs look into a
kid's toy check but I do after watching
this you do fully more appreciate like
people who are like
that's pretty dope and then like the
next movie comes out and he just like
falls into a rancor pit and it burps
yeah this it's a really cool
introduction of that character and then
but it's just a it's just like a
Christmas gift life Day gift to lumpy
lumpy watches it yeah
which begs the question of like yeah
dude this star wars characters exist as
like pop icons in the Star Wars universe
yeah it's like tales of that I think
it's like an animated tale of the
rebellion right it's like mythology it
was like a pirate root wasn't like a
pirate TV and then he had the brain a
propaganda videos party Alliance is
putting out did Luke Skywalker voice
himself yeah sounds like him yeah it
doesn't seem like a deep fake no yeah
cuz in universe the Star Wars characters
are heroes in universe yeah on
television just very strange and I can't
believe I said resistance when I met
rebellion what a snafu let's see what we
lack out of this brilliant piece of
Internet I'll see all the parts of Endor
that look like George Lucas's backyard
because that's where they are and meet
not so mysterious alien creatures like a
ferret a bunny chickens a lizard a moon
of Endor perfectly exact normal horses
as they strip out when little sci-fi
stores had to begin with and bring you
low-budget token where the dwarves are
dressed like Paddington hey where were
you in the Empire invaded Tony Gandalf
yeah so that was a run on the caramel
encouraged and I think we cut it just to
get a to get to the holiday special
quicker too and be just because it was
the other one only had one run so we
thought it would make more sense like
one run for each Ewok movie and then get
to the good stuff but if the if the
Ewoks can like hypnotize people with
their magic and they there's that really
fast one and runs around and stuff like
that could have come in handy when a
part came called where's Wilford Brimley
yeah he said he'd been there for a while
yeah he was on the other side of the
ridge yeah small move now we pick
because this takes place after it does
take place after we can
and it would what do they took place
before and wicket was like I did these
yeah yeah that's some serious lower
analysis right there yeah like you could
have really taken down some edits
Gandalf
Ewok time again though taina Gandalf hey
what else we cut you try to maintain
your last shred of sanity kids you just
don't understand how weird this is
it's like if the MCU made a special
about groots family celebrating tree day
where Roseanne flies the Quinn jet and
it ends with Chris Evans singing a
Christmas carol to the tune of you've
interesting weird enough to come up with
yeah this is a one-off as far as
strangeness goes for in all of pop
culture yep yeah I don't think there'll
ever be anything that's great no I don't
think this high profile and bizarre yeah
at the same time like this is on network
television yeah
to the entire today's a big deal yeah
weird all right don't forget drew
barrymore or less and don't care bear
grumpy bear justice for bender
messed with the bootcut it's something
hey sister night sister Jefferson jizz
Whalers a Mark Hamill sex golf no rum
babe a reaction of so low some Star Wars
stories here's some money go see a star
war rest and development yeah yeah I
know this takes place after Jedi because
wicked can talk but where was any of
this weird crap during Return of the
Jedi
unless falling death star debris mutated
indoors ecosystem resulting in mutated
predators and rific monsters cool thanks
rebellion do you say facts yeah yeah
wake up sheeple yeah that's right
because that would have slaughtered all
of them yep just weird like I'm sure
there's some in universe explanation for
like Kyber crystal radiation man oh
really
Wow interesting stuff guys that's yes
it's weird when they do multiple movies
in one but I don't we could have done a
whole one for the holiday special let's
be honest we could have but but when
else would we have ever done the Ewok
movie that would not have I mean the
holiday special is a lot of like right
yeah true true enough deep analysis on
Mark Hamill's makeup yeah it remains to
be seen whether these will be as
impactful culturally and fan wise as as
solo but I think they set a high bar for
for solo to be more memorable to meet
than the holiday special it's gonna have
to really pull out all the stops well
look I don't know if he's in solo but
Lumpy's Canon now because they put up
the trilogy of books that takes place
after Jetta that's supposed to bridge to
force awakens and Lumpy's in them really
awesome yeah lumping Canon Lumpy's Canon
his full name is like they really felt
the need to work him in there
great I hope he's in some peace Canon
then gourmand is Canon then Bea Arthur's
km yeah it's all canon guys if this then
what a fun game to play with star yeah
so everything's in the Canon
dan Merle's in the cannon I'm in the
cannon joestars in the cannon also in
the cannon you know I'm in the cannon
yep and next week we're gonna be in the
car gonna be in front of the cans are
gonna be aimed at us squarely hopefully
we can pull out a twist at the end thing
is he coming
yep yes that's your clue we'll see you
next week on Australian commentaries
[Music]
you